Charlie it's so Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool and now and welcome to
another episode of how to be English in
today MA my name is Charles and today
I'm going to be showing you the ancient
English art that is making a cup of tea
firstly you will need to get your tea
making equipment this consists of a
kettle complete with water a mug a tea
spoon milk
I prefer steady skim milk sugar for
those of you with a sweet tooth at least
but not last tea bags now that you have
all your equipment we can get started
first take your kettle and fill it with
water then plug the kettle into the plug
and boil the water while the kettle is
boiling we can prepare the cup for tea
bagging take the mug removed spigen and
insert one tea bag into the market if
you wish to have sugar in your tea
insert the sugar at this point I have a
sweet tooth so I prefer to sugars in my
tea
now the cup is ready for the water so we
will wait for the water to boil
it's ready take your kettle with boiling
water and pour the water in to the cup
then we stir then you take the tea bag
and you press it against the side of the
cup and remove the tea bag for build oh
now the tea is ready
for the milk I like my tea quite milky
and once again stir the tea you must
stir the tea quite a lot to make sure
that the sugar is dissolved and that the
infusion of the tea leaves combines with
the water and now the tea is ready to
drink ah delicious thanks for watching
how to be English see you next time
it tastes like
crap I swear you sure someone hasn't
pissed in that water pretty good